we're going to talk about Taylor Swift
boy have I missed out on this Taylor
Swift stuff I have I don't get it now
I'm not I'm not going at her she's a
colleague she's someone who's out on the
road she's on a tour I'm on a tour I get
it
what I've missed is I thought she had
one song
I thought she had that love story it's a
love story I had no idea she was the
biggest artist in the world
and I guess I'm not a white lady but
and and respect to her and what she's
done I this is like amazing
it's just one of those people like
I I understand Drake
I get you know what I mean like I'm not
a I'm not out of it
I know what pop culture is I know I know
who's a big and successful but Taylor
Swift I I guess I was surprised at the
but I guess she's the soundtrack to all
of these women's lives right their
breakups and the Heartbreak and the
heartache like Taylor Swift is the
soundtrack
to the Suburban like white woman's life
like
Taylor Swift is the song playing in
their head at every pivotal moment in
their life this is what I've been told
and I guess it's true because Arena
after Arena after a real who does she
think she is Sebastian matiscalco
it's there's so many and I and I respect
it
um what she's doing I I I don't do you
know any Taylor Swift it's like no one
knows anything
no no one no
what I mean the one it's a love story
and I know it because of tick tock I
wouldn't
now I'm sure she's doing she's got other
ones and I know that they're quite
popular I'm not I'm not saying this
woman does not deserve
it's but can we be honest for a minute
and I know that people might get mad at
me and this is not a dig to her at all
and this shouldn't be viewed as a dig at
her or to her it's terribly mediocre
right isn't it terribly mediocre and
that's not meant to offend it's just
from my observation
the music the compositions the lyrics
the performance
terribly mediocre and I don't mean and I
don't mean to say that
in any type of uh in a way that makes
anyone angry at me because
I imagine that's the goal I imagine
that's the goal and that's what people
enjoy
is the media I think that's what people
want now and and but her fans now are
showing up in uh diapers or wearing
adult diapers
to her concerts
and my mother's in a nursing home I'm
well I know what an adult diaper is I'm
well aware of an adult diaper but
they're wearing it in a non-fetish way
they're wearing it because they would
rather
[__] themselves
then miss
a Taylor Swift song of which I couldn't
gun to my head could not tell you what
one of them is other than love story I
would have no idea gun in my mouth I
thought oh no
but apparently there's so many good ones
it never ends there's so it's hit after
hit after hit a breakup I'm back I love
him again I hate him I'm back I moved I
don't know what else is there in the
white woman world I was at a coffee shop
and I saw a guy
whatever it is there's so many of these
that are of such consequence
such consequence uh that people would
rather defecate
in an arena with their friends
literally [__] literally stand there
while this [__] is playing music and
[__]
like like [__]
totally
entranced in the moment of a concert but
also [__]
and then with the [__] in your diaper
continue to enjoy the show
this is happening let's let's read this
because I didn't make this up
listen to this the amount of stress and
time it took me to get Taylor Swift
tickets I'll be getting an adult diaper
because I'm not missing a minute of it
questions for the audience would you
wear would you wear an adult diaper to a
three-hour concert in order not to miss
a single song well it seems like some
Taylor Swift fans are doing exactly that
in case you haven't been keeping up with
Taylor and her Mammoth heiress tour
the Superstar performs a whopping 44
songs she has 44 songs
from her
discography every Nikki Glaser is going
to kill me by the way when she if she
hears this
um and with three hours of non-stop
bangers Bops and ballots any time spent
queuing over the toilet could mean you
could miss at least one song adult
diapers
are the solution apparently
this is this is real
Tick Tock user whoever recently went
viral on the app after posting a video
of herself attempting to put on one
underneath her fearless themed outfit
and it turns out there's quite a few
swifties who have deployed the very same
tactic another user wrote no one knows
I'm wearing an adult diaper for this
alongside a clip of them in their seat
they literally best case they're pissing
right
best case here
the swifties are saying if I have to
dribble a little bit I don't want to
miss whatever
however
some of them are [__]
there's there's no way
that some of these people
are not using this opportunity
to as an adult [__] themselves
because the bathrooms are
so long this is why I don't do lots of
Arenas because I don't want this to be
happening I don't want my fans to have
to suffer through that indignity I want
to touch on also